en las calles de kabul una protesta
autorizada está en marcha lejos de las
escenas de caos que han surgido en las
últimas semanas estas mujeres marchan
unas al lado de las otras rodeadas por
hombres armados protegiendo las arengas
de ala es grande y carteles que apoyan
la toma por parte de los talibanes un
poco antes las mujeres dieron una charla
en una de las salas de conferencia en
kabul
la mayoría de gente especialmente las
mujeres que han expresado su descontento
con los talibanes en los últimos 20 años
ha hablado con la idea y el conocimiento
equivocado sobre ellos
[Música]
comprometidas con las políticas del
grupo talibán y su segregación de género
todas estaban cubiertas de la cabeza a
los pies de acuerdo con las nuevas
reglas de educación en el país
me gustaría felicitar a todos los
musulmanes y la nación oprimida de
afganistán por su libertad pero también
la derrota de la otan liderada por eeuu
alrededor del mundo la preocupación ha
crecido por los derechos de las mujeres
bajo reglas de los talibanes ellos dicen
que se quieren distanciar de sus
anteriores políticas y que las mujeres
podrán ahora trabajar de acuerdo con los
principios del islam pero semanas
después de tomar control del país aún no
se han proporcionado detalles más claros
esta semana el grupo talibán dio a
conocer su gobierno interino por ahora
ni una sola mujer hace parte de este